i was walking my dog in chelsea one time
i was young man
i was probably in my 20s and cute
and i was the morning and i was uh i had
my pitbull there
and a guy comes up and he's like nice
dog man
and i noticed he was wearing sweatpants
you know the kind of the
cloth sweatpants and you can see a man's
dick i can see his dong
and uh uh you can see the outline of his
dong and i was like all right
like there's no way yet not yet he was
just kind of
he was just sitting there you know just
sitting maybe
maybe there was definitely some blood
flow but i couldn't tell was a hot day
so uh he's like uh yeah man you got a
dog huh i bet you good with that dog
and i was like and i was i'm all right i
was like yeah yeah yeah and his hair was
a little
i was like all right this guy's just a
little off and he's like yeah man
you you've been up you wake up you early
rising and i go
not not usually bro now i'm down now i'm
already no
now i'm breaking now the spidey senses
are like yeah he's trying to
don't [ __ ] try to bulldog me out for
me man because i'll [ __ ] you don't [ __ ]
you're not now you know me i'm insecure
and i get macho so i'm like and you got
a pitbull with me yeah yeah yeah and
this guy's a little bigger than me too
so i'm already like alright
so he goes uh he goes yeah yeah man you
got kids
and i go now he goes what are you
waiting for
so i couldn't get out of here no he was
what you waiting for man i bet you get
it you got some good kids man yes
what though yeah yeah and he goes he
goes i bet you have some good kids man
i'm looking at you right now you're
gonna have some good looking kids
now i look down and he's just tin hut
well
he's not ten hep but just the the back
of his dong because it's bent over you
understand
oh he has
on those sweats that's a great that's a
great way to put it
and he's gonzo knows in me right now
he's not gonna know god and then he
reaches down
i'd rather have it full of wrecked oh
god he's creepy lazy a lazy heavy gonzo
nose
and he reached down and just kind of
adjust his
[ __ ] out of here bro how strange is that
see ya like
i called you outside i don't know if you
remember this i was uh
going on a run i ran up uh down santa
monica right where
it's almost on the the hill there where
that looks down on the beach
i'm running this guy with this giant
german shepherd
and again dude was in sweats watch
[ __ ] people in sweats
and he goes hey looking for a dog man
and this is what at the time when i was
i went yeah i actually
am and it was like this big-ass german
shepherd goes yeah i can always tell
and i'm like god that's strange we start
talking back and forth and he's like
just you like you like to run a lot like
yeah run a little bit yeah how many
miles usually do you look like you do
some modeling
yeah for sure uh anyways and starts
going and goes
yeah i know mark coleman i'm like no
doubt that's cool man have a good day
and he's like yeah hold on
you so do you want to you want a dog i'm
like maybe you know i'll
look around us yeah for sure man he
keeps going similar to sting yeah i'm
like oh he wants
something yeah if i want something my
[ __ ]
or my mouth yeah he wants he wants your
mud you want something while his dog
like
sits in the corner and watches he wants
and then i just go he goes you live
around here mario
nah i've ran far man i'm i'm back that
way so
how i could tell my my dick sensor went
off i'm like oh no see you dick sensor
yeah see you man i go to leave and he
goes bro let me get your number
that's so easy let me get your number
some guys who are aggressive
no i did i don't hurt his feelings i go
yeah
yeah why not why not and i gave him
the first part of my number and then
switch up the whole back yeah
and then he goes i'm gonna call you
right now just so you have mine
i go ah just text me man it'll i'm sure
i got it because
he wanted me to get my phone out dude
you know
that's a guy who relentless guy who
[ __ ] dude see there are certain guys
that
that want to get banged and those guys
are way less aggressive
it's the dudes that that that are going
to [ __ ] you like i was in bro
shepherd that was from the game of
thrones i don't know if you saw the
shirt today yeah
from the game of thrones with one of
those big wolves
the the giant one yeah him and that
giant game of thrones
german shepherd trying to [ __ ] yeah
that's a santa monica well that's a dog
that he could sick on you if you don't
if you don't that's why you don't
serve a fake number yeah yo man you
number one
yeah i'll see why not a big dark seven
two
you're big brown and thick he's trying
to [ __ ] he wanted that back tell you
this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected